Think back to when you were a child visiting
your grandparent’s home.
Do you recall a distinct scent when you walked
through the door?
Many people do and it turns out, it’s not
just in your head.
Gerontologist and author of A New Wrinkle:
What I Learned from Older People Who Never
Acted Their Age, Dr. Eric Shapira, says it
is difficult to pinpoint the cause or one
main reason for the smell; it is a process
of what happens to the body as we age.
Many studies show that the body’s chemistry
changes from within as we get older producing
a certain scent.
Some may describe it as musty.
Some may call it stale.
Maybe a bit medicinal.
Here’s the surprising part: Grandma or Grandpa
may smell different.
But, they don’t smell BAD.
A recent research study done by Johan Lundström
of the Monell Chemical Senses Center published
in PLOS ONE tested the odors from the underarms
of middle-aged adults and the elderly.
The result?
Middle-aged men smelled the worst, according
to those surveyed.
The good news?
Grandpa was considered second-best, and actually
pleasant smelling.
Middle-aged women came out on top of the list
of most-enjoyable body odors.
The study was conducted by attaching absorbent
pads to the lining of the armpits of shirts.
The shirts were then worn by volunteers of
various ages for five consecutive nights while
they slept.
In order for other smells not to seep when
the shirts weren’t being worn, they were
stored in sealed plastic bags during the day.
The volunteers were also required to use scentless
soaps and shampoos during the experiment and
not to eat or expose themselves to strong
smelling external things like perfume or cigarette
smoke.
After the five days were up, the pads were
collected and placed in sealed jars ready
to be opened and sniffed by other volunteers
to judge the smelliness and to see if people
could correctly identify the general age of
the person who wore the pad (young, middle-age,
and old-age).
The results?
The volunteers were able to correctly identify
which pads were worn by old people most of
the time, though that was about the extent
of the accuracy.
While they did also detect a distinct difference
between the middle-aged and young, they were
not able to accurately identify which was
which in most cases.
So what exactly is thought to be causing this
change in smell as we age?
It’s still somewhat up for debate, but it
is thought that there are many factors involved.
One factor, according to the aforementioned
physician, Eric Shapira, is simple dehydration.
Older people tend to be less thirsty, which
results in them being predominately more dehydrated
and shedding more dry skin.
Dead skin cells can carry a musty smell.
In addition, Shapira notes that older people
see a decline in oral hygiene over the years
due to less efficient brushing.
Oral hygiene, of course, can also affect one’s
scent.
A more scientific approach to this question
was taken by a team of Japanese researchers
in 2000.
They discovered that a concentration of the
chemical 2-nonenal, which is an odoriferous
substance found in sweat and on your skin,
increased as people aged, with people in their
70s having as much as three times as much
of it as middle-aged individuals.
It’s thought that the extra 2-nonenal is
coming from the breakdown of more prevalent
omega-7 fatty acids on our skin as we age.
(Interestingly, besides being perhaps a major
culprit in the smell of an elderly individual,
2-nonenal is also a key component in the smell
of beer.)
An elderly person’s living environment is
also thought to be a factor.
How many of us know a relative who keeps,
or hoards, everything from years gone by?
Brenda Thompson of Tri-Country Home Nursing
says,
All those old books and papers, old linens
and clothes — they all harbor dust and dampness
and give off a musty odor that can pervade
the whole house.
If you moved into that house in 1945, those
books may have been there for 60 years.
I’ve seen drapes that have been there that
long, too.
Here’s another odd thing about the changing
of how we smell as we age: as we grow older,
nearing age 80, males tend to smell more and
more like women, with this change thought
by some to be hormonal based, though exactly
what’s going on isn’t yet perfectly clear.